so in order to cook a food it is
necessary to heat the inside of the food
up to some critical temperature and we
discussed previously that that critical
temperature for most foods be at steak
or tofu or whatever it is the you ite
happens to be in the range of 60 degrees
Celsius or there abouts because that's
where the proteins and the food unfold
and interact with each other to cause
the food to become cooked we pointed out
that there is a paradox which is that if
you look at the recipes for cooking
foods they tend to require temperatures
that are much above that critical
temperature so that when you cook a
steak in the oven for example you're you
use a temperature which is I don't know
180 degrees Celsius or so even though
you only want the inside of the steak to
get to around 60 degrees Celsius and
then we basically explained or started
to hint at the reason why and the reason
why is that it turns out that there are
two chemical reactions that need to
occur in order for food to be cooked one
is the the texture on the inside has to
change and the other is is you need
there to be browning reactions on the
outside and we discussed that those
occur at around 120 degrees Celsius so
now we want to try to put all of this
information together and try to think
through why it's hard to cook a steak so
that is the subject of this of this
discussion if you don't like steak I
myself don't eat steak then you can
really think about your favorite food
why it is hard to cook a potato why it
is hard to cook tofu why it is hard to
cook fish and whatever it is the lucky
what I'm about to say applies so you
might for example choose to cook your
steak at 180 or 190 degrees Celsius so
we want the internal temperature which
starts out at room temperature because
your steak might have been resting on
the countertop before you put it in your
oven so maybe the initial temperature is
say 23 degrees Celsius you want to raise
that up to about 60 degrees Celsius
because that's when the steak is cooked
and you also want the outside to get to
a temperature of 120 degrees Celsius now
the first problem that you have when you
sort of think about this and the problem
is so we want to get the outside through
120 degrees Celsius is that you all
recall that the boiling point of water
is at 100 degrees Celsius and the major
ingredient of steak is water and so that
means that initially you can't get the
steak above 100 degrees
Celsius because because it's made mostly
of water and water the maximum
temperature it can get to is a hundred
degree Celsius before it changes phases
and actually becomes a gas so if you
want so how are we going to heat the
steak up to 120 degrees Celsius the way
we're going to do that is we're going to
have to evaporate off some amount of the
water around the outside of the steak if
we do that and there's no water in the
outside to imagine the whole edge of the
steak has no water and only the inside
of the steak actually has the water then
the outside once it's at once it's
gotten no water you can actually heat it
up to close to the temperature of the
oven or whatever you want so you can get
it up to 120 or 180 degrees or whatever
so if you imagine the temperature
profile across the steak and here we'll
draw it so at the outside of the steak
right outside where the steak is the
temperature is the temperature in the
oven which is say 180 degrees Celsius at
the surface of the state you'd like to
get it to 120 degrees or so maybe 130 so
that you get the browning reactions to
be how you liked to taste theirs then
could be a very thin layer where the
temperature goes down from the 120
hundred 30 degrees to the hundred
degrees which is the boiling point of
water which is how hot the outermost
water layer of the steak will be and
then what you would like is for it to
get to be 60 degrees or whatever your
temperature is in the middle and so you
can imagine a curve which basically goes
down 60 degrees in the middle now the
problem is is if you achieve this target
with the way that one typically achieves
it when one is cooking as one puts a
thermometer in the center and says hello
the temperature is at 60 degrees Celsius
the steak is cooked and you see that
that's true in the center of the steak
but the whole outside of the steak is
necessarily at a temperature which is
higher than 60 degrees because otherwise
you won't hit the browning reactions
that you need on the outside to create
the flavor molecules that we want and
that actually in his essence is why as
actually it's one of the reasons why
it's so hard to cook a steak